استلقى ذؤوب أرضا ***  وتأمل غيمات بيضاء
ردد ما أزهى الألوان ***  وبلوني القاتم لا أرضى
أنا لوني بشع وقبيح ***  لا يعجب أحدا ويريح
حين تراني الحيوانات ***  تهرب من وجهي وتصيح
طرأت للذئب الأفكار ***  فأصطبغ بلون الأشجار
انتقدته الحيوانات ***  ذئب أنت أم صبار
ذئب أنت أم صبار؟
عاد إلى المنزل يتحسر ***  فتذكر معطفه الأحمر
قال جميل سيغيرني ***  خرج ولم يحتمل الحر
ذؤوب ذؤوب المسكين لا تحزن ***  ذؤوب ذؤوب المسكين لا تحزن
زاد وجه الذئب عبوس ***  فأنطلق لبيت الطاووس
اقترض بعض الريشات ***  ومشى يختال كعروس
صار الكل هنا مدهوش ***  هل ينبت للذئب الريش
أغدا يضع كطير بيض ***  أيبني فوق الشجر عشوش
أيبني فوق الشجر عشوش؟
أحرج ذؤوب من نفسه ***  أدرك كيف جميل لونه
خلق الله المخلوقات ***  كل فريق وله شكله
ذؤوب ذؤوب المسكين لا تحزن ***  ذؤوب ذؤوب المسكين لا تحزن